[Music]
when's your special coming out
it goes in for color
tomorrow wow
I'm skilled and then how long is that
gonna take I'm scared and then after
that
in theory I could just upload it the
next day wow in theory
yeah
yeah sucks because you I watch it now
and I'm like
I would change all of it really no not
really I mean it's good for the next one
though because they don't know
yeah I mean that's probably always going
to be a thing yeah you're never you'll
never uh
be done yeah it's really fun I need it
to come out so I can actually get booked
in La again yeah
why everyone just thinks I'm a YouTuber
oh that sucks they don't think I do
stand up that's annoying I mean that'll
definitely open doors for sure 100 did
you see Matt Rife just uploaded like a
49 minute special or something that's
just like oh super shittily recorded and
I feel like there's gonna be this new
wave of stand up where it's like it's
primarily content yeah and it's just
comedians film every single show no
matter what and then always just upload
them as YouTube videos like even if it's
like this wasn't really a special it was
I don't think I don't know I didn't
really watch any of it but it's all set
what it's just like us yeah it was like
a set like this doesn't look like a
special right
um
maybe it's a different and he just
uploaded one like
like a cup like a month or two ago yeah
have you seen the [__] how much how
many tickets you [__] sold though
yeah I looked at his tour it was every
single one of his Instagram comments is
like I can't believe I couldn't get
tickets I couldn't get tickets why the
[__] like they're taking like 300
bucks yeah I couldn't get them yeah it's
insane yeah he's doing well I mean it's
just like a testament to how like I
don't know how fast people blow up
nowadays oh Matt's been at it for a
while though no I know but if you go
back and look at his Instagram his like
his post from like a year ago have like
not that many likes oh no I know I'm
just saying he had like yeah yeah he hit
his stride for sure I guess it like
restores my faith in stand up yeah you
know sort of related to what you're
saying it's not like one to one but yeah
like seeing that
you can put yourself out there like you
can record like a live version of
yourself you can put it out there and
then it is people still are choosing to
like want to come see you live yeah
because my fear after covid was everyone
was just
I granted people want to go outside but
I was jaded on the idea that people
would want to come see Live Comedy I
feel like people are always gonna
want to be in the room now yeah the way
that it's kind of evolving yeah where
it's a lot more crowd work a lot more
natural because you hear over the past
like
you know however many 15 years you'd
hear a lot of like I don't like this
person's special or their stand up but I
love their podcast yeah but now that's
sort of like blending people now being
encouraged to just film every single set
yeah and just get a funny moment yeah
that up I think that's a tough part too
for if you're just starting in comedy
Now
and you get like a six minute set
it's like you have to do you're just
like
yeah I think you feel pressure to like
get a funny moment whereas I think
I actually think if you're like somehow
at the end of this bonus episode and
you're starting comedy I would say film
yourself but not for the internet give
yourself at least
one to two years I think I think people
maybe convince themselves at certain
moments on stage are better than they
are because they go I need to have a
clip yeah and it's like I think if give
yourself some time but I kind of feel
like I'm the type of person that needs
some sort of validation to encourage me
to keep yeah per like keep pursuing
through the hard [__] sure so I need
that like whether it's like something in
the Arts or even something like in
business you just like
want like little proof of concept like
one sale one something some like you
know I don't know somebody liking your
thing or whatever sure like with music
I've been doing that like I've been
posting the [__] I'm making on
SoundCloud
and like I go back and listen to it two
months later and I've already gotten a
lot better so that sounds like [__] I'm
like I wish I didn't [__] post this
yeah but yeah yet all the comments are
like oh I really like this and that
encouraged me to make the next one yeah
that's fair I think comedy is one of
those unique ones where
I don't know I feel like there's like a
lot of intangibles with comedy like
I think
comedy is one of those things where you
can a bit can look so good in your
memory but then you watch it on video
and you go
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah as I think
sometimes that's another Pitfall I think
is people remember how the bits how
remember bits how they felt on stage
yeah and they don't consider that that
feeling doesn't translate yeah so I
think sometimes the standard you say
riskier stuff in person and everyone
contextually is like okay we know that
you're just trying to be funny here and
maybe it doesn't land but whatever yeah
but you throw that [__] on the internet
and you might
[__] your career up or something ah I
see what you're saying some unintended
way or
I don't know it's a weird it's a weird
balance it's not that you have to like
self-censor or anything I'm just saying
like
comedy specifically I think is a strange
one with Clips because it can massively
benefit your career but it's it's hard
to know when you should be doing that
yeah I think it's also changing in that
all the material doesn't have to be this
polished yeah yeah it's just kind of
like oh I had this thought yeah and it
you know makes you wonder what's better
yeah
it's uh it's very
cool times weird times
it's different yeah where is Chad and
JT's show The Improv the Hollywood
improv the old main room nice
Tuesday night what's happening are we
[__] depressed or what is that why
we're here on a Tuesday Jesus all right
anyways I think your mic's stuck [__]
sorry this is part of my set
[__] what I want to talk about
um
the sub
oh the sub yeah let me do a deep dive on
that nah I'm [__] around I was
[__] this chick
um
my wife actually yeah locked it in
dumbass I know no I'm kidding well you
know I love her for real love her crazy
thing about marriage is like um there
you go it's like it [__] like you're
[__] like your dad and [__] is like
[__] like
[__] don't do it and [__] and you're
like [__] I might you know and then
you do it
um
thank you yeah me too
but I don't really get a crowd work
honestly
um
kind of [__] nervous huh no no hold
on hold on I got one more in here
oh y'all hear about that uh like Russia
Ukraine situation
yeah how like the Wagner group tried to
yeah do like a little coup
yeah it turns out that guy's name is uh
pregosian
[Applause]
no that's actually his name I don't know
why you're laughing his name is
progosian
but um
I like to refer to him as [__]
because I kind of think he's more like a
chicken the way he flew the coup
get it like Coop yeah
um yesterday I was a [__] this chick
it's like my wife and [__] and
um yeah I nutted on her face that's my
time thank you
[Laughter]